okay three awards that's crazy feel how
you feeling
so excited i feel so honored to get to
be a part of this canadian country music
family and
so thrilled to get to be celebrating all
this this year even through the distance
i'm so thankful the show's still
happening
way to go ccmas and uh oh yeah
i'm so excited yeah yeah what did that
experience feel like like shooting
because you did the acms too so what
what did this award show
experience feel like when you're
performing to no one
it's such a strange thing i mean to me
that's just the most important part
is everybody in the audience and it's
missing that
really special element and there's thank
goodness that's a thing that can't
really be replaced
you know i think it makes it seem you
were more special and
whenever we get to to be back to that
feeling it will just feel even more
sacred i think but
i'm just so thankful that everybody's
pushed through in these times to
go through all the extra hoops and
requirements to keep everybody safe and
still be able to pull off the show so
there's something kind of spiritual
about
an empty venue or playing into a space
where you just kind of
imagine where everybody's energy is and
kind of imagine heaven opening up a
little bit but it's like it just sort of
fills up that way
so i'm thankful for that yeah so yeah so
you got the three ccmas you got two acms
last week
where are you gonna keep these things
that's a lot of awards you gotta make
space for
it is a lot i don't know that's so weird
to think about
and i mean everyone was calling 2019
your breakout year but i mean this year
in terms of this recognition is
it's crazy but obviously we're having a
very weird 2020.
so how does this fit into your 2020 is
it just like
a weird situation it is weird but what a
like
brilliant just sort of streak of
of just joy and and feeling a part of
the community of music i think that's
been
the most special thing and um it is a
really weird time to celebrate and
there's a lot there's a lot of happiness
in the world right now and i think
now more than ever i'm grateful for the
music and the way that it can lift up
our spirits and
i know that you know watching these
shows and seeing everybody's
performances
and even just feeling the love through
the distance has certainly lifted my
spirits so
always grateful for music and especially
right now
yeah and so one of these sims you got
was for the collaboration with miranda
and
and the other ladies now i think you
just did another award-winning
collaboration
tonight on the ccmas so how did that
feel with those ladies on stage
it was amazing i look up to those girls
so much
and their voices and the music that they
make and
you know i'm i absolutely love getting
to celebrate lindsay's music
and megan's music and i have looked up
to
carolyn don johnson since i was a little
kid following along to her lyric booklet
in the back seat of the car
just dreaming of getting just to write
songs like her
so um it was a very special moment to
get to all sing
together tonight yeah it was amazing and
i love what you said in your speech
about
footsteps or creating footsteps do you
think
like is that really a conscious thing
that you think about when you're when
you're making music and when you're
developing your career about
the mark you're making or the the role
model you're being for younger girls
thank you for saying that i mean
absolutely
it's just kind of like what an honor to
get to do this to have the opportunity
to
to sing and to say things through a song
and to make
someone hopefully feel less alone and to
me that is
such a great honor and is definitely
something that i i
care about so much in my heart it very
much i think
is something i'm conscious of all the
time yeah well i think you're making
some very good footsteps
thank you i appreciate that
congratulations well deserved how are
you going to celebrate tonight
ice cream any particular kind
um i don't know maybe cookies and cream
i'm not sure
that's a good one well enjoy yeah have a
night to bajo
thank you